bonanza creek ranch has had two people
accidentally shot this is script's
assistant mamie mitchell calling 9-1-1
immediately after helena hutchins was
fatally wounded by alec baldwin she says
that the hollywood veteran should have
known better that it was his
responsibility to check the gun wasn't
loaded before firing and mitchell has
taken on one of america's highest
profile lawyers to sue baldwin himself
for the trauma she's suffered since in
our opinion
mr baldwin
chose to play russian roulette
when he fired a gun
without checking it
and without having the armorer do so in
his presence mitchell says she was
standing fewer than four feet from
hutchins seen here in the woolly hat
inside this church set when the 42 year
old was killed
she says the scene they were rehearsing
for would not have required a gun to be
fired
then an explosion
deafening loud gunshot
i was stunned
i heard someone moaning and i turned
around and my director was falling
backwards and holding his upper body and
i turned around toward alec and i saw
helena going down to the left of me
mitchell has worked in the film industry
for 40 years she says her career may now
be over because of the trauma including
the moment she found out hutchins had
died in hospital i stood in my driveway
screaming
i'll never forget what happened on the
set of rust that day
i relived the shooting and the sound of
the explosion
from the gun over and over again
i'm depressed i don't feel safe i feel
like at any moment anything could happen
to me
and to those that i care about that are
standing close to me
the production team including baldwin
say safety of cast and crew is always
their top priority and that they're
conducting their own internal review of
procedures
almost one month since helena hutchins
died while making a film every scene of
this tragedy continues to be played out
in public martha kellner sky news